so in 1950 alan turing wrote the paper
that formulated the touring test yes and
he opened the paper with the question
can machines think
so what do you think can machines think
let me ask you this question absolutely
machines can think um certainly as well
as
humans can think
um right we're meat machines
um just because they're not currently
made out of meat is just you know an
engineering solution decision
um and so on so um
of course of course machines can think i
think that there was a lot of
um
damage done by people
misunderstanding uh touring's imitation
game
and
focus on
trying to
trying to get a chat bot to
fool other people into thinking it was
human
and so on that that's that's not a
terrible test in and of itself but it
shouldn't be your one and only test for
intelligence
so you uh in terms of tests of
intelligence uh you know
with the lobner prize which is a very
kind of
you want to say a more strict
formulation of the touring test as
originally formulated and then there's
something like alexa prize which is more
i would say a more interesting
formulation of the test which is like
uh
ultimately the metric is how long does a
human want to talk to the hai system so
it's like
the goal is you want it to be 20 minutes
it's basically
not just have a convincing um
conversation but more like a compelling
one or a fun one or an interesting one
and that that seems like more to the
spirit
maybe of um
of what uh touring was imagining but
what for you do you think in the space
of tests is a is a good test like when
you see a system based on psych that
passes that test
you'd be like damn
we've created something special here
the the test has to be something
involving
depth of reasoning and recursiveness of
reasoning the ability to answer repeated
why questions about the answer you just
gave
it's how many why questions in a row can
you keep answering something something
like that and
um
have like a young curious child and an
ai system and how long will anya system
last before it wants to quit yes and
again that's not the only test another
one has to do with argumentation in
other words here's a proposition um
come up with pro and con arguments
for it and uh try and
give me convincing arguments on both
sides uh and
so that's that's another important kind
of ability that um the system needs to
be able to exhibit in order to really be
intelligent i think so there's certain i
mean if you look at ibm watson and like
certain impressive accomplishments for
very specific
tests almost like a demo right
there is some
like i talked to the guy who led
the
the jeopardy effort
and there's some kind of hard-coding
heuristics uh tricks that you try to
pull it all together to make the thing
work in the end for this thing right
that seems to be one of the lessons with
ai is like
that's the fastest way to get a solution
that's pretty damn impressive so so here
here's what i would say is that
as impressive as that was
it made some mistakes but more
importantly
many of the mistakes it made were
mistakes which no human would have made
yeah um and
so part of the
the the
new
or augmented touring tests would have to
be
and the mistakes you make are ones which
humans don't basically look at and say
what
yeah
so for example
there was a
a question about which 16th century
italian politician blah blah blah
and watson said ronald reagan
so most americans would have gotten that
question wrong but they would never have
said ronald reagan as an answer
because
you know among the things they know is
that he lived relatively recently and
people don't really live 400 years and
you know things like that so that that's
i think a very important thing which is
um if it's making mistakes which
no normal sane human would have made
then that's a really bad sign and if
it's not making those kinds of mistakes
then that's a good sign and i don't
think it's any one very very simple test
i think it's all of the things you
mentioned all the things i mentioned
there's really a battery of tests which
together if it passes almost all of
these tests it would be hard to argue
that it's not intelligent and if it
fails some several of these tests it's
really hard to argue that it really
understands what it's doing that it
really is generally intelligent so to
pass all of those tests
you know we've talked a lot about psych
and knowledge and reasoning
do you think this ai system would need
to have
some other human-like elements
for example a body
or a physical manifestation in this
world
and another one which seems to be
fundamental to
the human experience is consciousness
the subjective experience of what it's
like to actually be you
do you think he needs those to be able
to pass all those tests and to achieve
general intelligence it's a good
question i think in the case of a body
uh no i know there are a lot of people
like penrose who would have uh disagreed
with me and so on
and
and others but
no i don't think it needs to have a body
in order to be
intelligent i think that it needs to be
able to
talk about
uh having a body and having sensations
and having emotions and so on it doesn't
actually have to
have
all of that but it has to understand it
in the same way that helen keller was
perfectly intelligent and able to talk
about um colors and sounds and um shapes
and
and so on um even though
she didn't directly experience all the
same things that the rest of us do so
knowledge of it and being able to
correctly
make use of that
is certainly an important facility but
actually having a body
if you believe that that's just a kind
of religious or mystical belief you
can't really argue for or against it i
suppose um it's it's just something that
some people
that some people believe what about the
like an extension of the body which is
consciousness i mean like it feels like
something to be here
sure but you know what what does that
really mean it's like well if i talk to
you you say things which make me believe
that you're conscious
i know that i'm conscious but that's you
know you're just taking my word for it
now
but
in the same sense psych is conscious in
that same sense already where of course
it understands it's a computer program
it understands where and when it's
running it understands who's talking to
it it understands what its task is what
its goals are what its current problem
is that it's working on it understands
how long it's spent on things what it's
tried it understands what it's done in
the past
and so on
and
you know if if we want to call that
consciousness then yes psych is already
conscious but i don't think that i would
ascribe anything
mystical to that again some people would
but i would i would say that you know
other than other than our own personal
experience of consciousness um we're
just treating everyone else in the world
um so to speak um at their word about
being conscious and so if
if a computer program if an ai is able
to
exhibit
all the same kinds of
response as you would expect of a
conscious entity
then you know doesn't doesn't it deserve
the label of consciousness just as much
you